I can't believe I have to say this but
like just because you're a woman does
not mean you are inherently good you can
be crazy you can be destructive and
that's what I like about shows like
House of the Dragon is that it shows
destructive capabilities that are both
masculine and feminine
the next James Bond films will have
bigger roles for women and a more
sensitive 007 according to the producers
who said bond is evolving just as men
revolving this is from the telegraph
producers said Daniel Craig's successor
will continue the work of cracking Bond
open emotionally as the franchise seeks
to evolve next-gen bonds film will have
bigger roles for women more sensitive
007 Bond is evolving Barbara broccoli
said that the next actor will take the
role continue the work of Daniel Craig
Craig's last film no time to die
humanize bond by making him a devoted
family man also featured media roles for
female characters
what are your thoughts on this
so I think partially it makes sense to
me and partially it doesn't
um I'm glad that the strategy isn't to
just
oh have a female you know play James
Bond and completely change the character
because James Bond is a male character
and I think an important aspect of
having more female characters and female
Heroes should come with creating new
Heroes for females or you know new roles
for females uh but the idea of making
James Bond more
sensitive I guess I would ask what they
would mean by that I think part of
what's very attractive about James Bond
is that he is a macho uh character who's
very who's very powerful physically but
also mentally that physical strength
that is very we encourage that in men
you know specifically when they have
very difficult jobs like I think a
couple couple weeks ago you spoke to
someone who's who's in the high rungs of
the CIA right and it's not it's not an
easy thing to be doing work like that it
takes a lot of mental fortitude and
that's not to say that women can't do it
or men can't do it it's just a different
type of strength that looks very
masculine when when a man like James
Bond is doing and I think that's what
makes him super attractive I think if we
take that and break it down and in the
way that you know every every male
character these days has gotten this
like deconstruction that's happening to
him where uh maybe he's a lot more
emotional maybe he's a lot warm
you know showing his vulnerabilities and
stupid that's definitely the biggest one
I think that's not the right approach to
take to male characters I think men who
watch you know watch the movies they
look for inspiration is that how can I
to emulate strength but that shouldn't
ever come at the cost of then you don't
your emotions don't exist you're not a
real person you don't get to feel
anything it should never come to that
there are always extremes to anything
right uh so I think if they go too
extreme in the other end where he stops
being what makes James Bond so exciting
and interesting I think that would be a
really big mistake but I'm also glad
that it's not the sort of
1950s approach to how masculine and
feminine uh people would interact with
each other right uh where there was
definitely a lot more misogyny in in the
1950s and 60s and the way the female
characters were treated it's very
different and I think best Berlin was a
very big shift right she was this she
was a great female character to
introduce to well obviously she was in
the books but it was very different in
the movies I like that approach where
it's become more of this equal thing but
it shouldn't it shouldn't be that James
Bond stops being James Bond I think the
concern that people have is that
James's character gets eviscerated and
he's left as sort of this husk of a man
yes we've seen I mean you do these
amazing video essays online and one of
the best examples are two of the best
examples I think have been Loki what
happened to him and then Thor and what
happened to him as well like just
completely gutted from being capable
confident guys that could overcome
things to I mean how would you describe
what's happened to their trajectory
I think it's
um it's a public humiliation I I think
it to me the way those characters got
written and how they evolved from let's
say their initial introduction onto the
onto the screen it felt as if uh the
writers were exacting some form of
Revenge on on these characters
um and taking all of the things that
made them exciting interesting to let's
just make them really stupid and let's
Eclipse them with the the their obvious
counterparts that are going to be better
than them right and that's the female
version there's a female Loki there's a
female Thor and I think
um it was less obvious with the war
where they just you know where Jane
wasn't necessarily a bad character in
the way that she was written or anything
like that but
um but they just really dumbed down Thor
you know he's
his outfit his hair the fact that he
grabs his
hammer and and uh yeah his hammer and it
looks like a witch's broom and he rides
it was just so it was so such a farce to
take a man that that is supposed to be
this God right and to completely make
him this joke and they took all the
ideas that they built out in Ragnarok
and then just he took it so much further
that uh it just it became and it was
embarrassing it was embarrassing to
watch him what about Loki
uh Loki it was less obvious but
you know it was it was similar things
that he's bumbling he's dropping things
he's breaking things you know he's he's
not aware of the mission he's kind of
dancing around and singing for some
reason and and uh forgetting that he
needs to be in Disguise and and it's
it's uh female Loki what was her name um
Sylvie she's the one who has her wits
about her and she has to remind him that
you are uh you're being a real idiot
right now and so it was things like that
that um even with Loki oh the dressing
Downs he received repeatedly right even
from um Owen Wilson's character where he
says to him like calm down for a second
you know you're or him repeatedly
repeatedly having to affirm that he's
better than the other Loki how come the
other Loki has more protection or
security than him and it's hard to then
remember that when you look back on the
first Avengers film where Loki's this
formidable uh
you know almost like I think uh nerd
erotic said this on the stream I did
last week on on critical drinkers saying
it but he said it almost it was like he
was resurrected from hell right but
that's how he was introduced into the
Avengers as uh this really formidable
force and then now he's just this
dancing monkey and he's he's no threat
at all he's in fact easily he just
transitions away from his power you know
a power hungry phase
surely though for a long time women
haven't been as represented when it
comes to superhero movies and stuff like
that is it not a good thing is it not a
an advantage that we've now got females
that are putting men in their place and
telling them what they think about them
I think it would be just as good as as
men putting women in their place and
telling them that they're not so good I
think anything that is a reaction
um that's such an intense pendulum swing
where you're you're motivated not by
storytelling or or sharing deeper human
stories but instead you're motivated by
Revenge I think nothing good ever comes
out of that it's good that there are
more roles for women that's great but
it's not good if those roles uh actually
create a false perception of what it
really means to be a woman
uh and what I mean by that is so much of
so many of the Marvel super female
superheroes are so perfect that it's
impossible to connect with them
it's impossible to know
um it you know a deep connection with a
character comes from seeing yourself in
that person's place
and if you if you do connect with these
people you think your life is perfect
and you think that you will you sh you
don't anything that wrong that goes in
your life is undeserved right and that's
a lot of the way that these stories are
written is that there's not the
traditional hero's journey there's not
the development of the power it's more
of like you're born you have the power
um and if anyone doubts it it's coming
from a place of malice right so even
with female Loki right what does Loki
say to her your you run rings around
them you're amazing how did you learn
magic I taught myself right and you'll
see that theme throughout Marvel even in
Shang Chi which is a movie I actually
liked
um uh but the hit shangshi's sister
whose name I can't remember right now
but uh his sister she was not allowed to
train with the boys and she just taught
herself and she's even better than Shang
Chi right she gives him that good old
kick in the groin to prove of that point
and I think what would traditionally
happen is that if someone taught
themselves anything
the idea would be that there have major
holes in their knowledge that then
um then they would be really they would
basically suffer consequences for not
knowing about those gaps and then have
to have to fill that in and then Excel
to that next level but that doesn't
happen an example of that might be the
um classic MMA Underdog Story where the
guy gets angry because the bully beat
him up I stole his girl and he goes and
kind of learns on his own but goes into
a MMA gym finally to find out that he
doesn't know grappling or he doesn't
know Brazilian Jiu Jitsu he has the
gumption and the motivation to go and do
the thing but he needs to discipline it
he needs to be able to Wrangle it within
the existing format so there's this sort
of wild Brilliance that people come in
with but it still needs to be honed in
that way yet it seems that it's
something that is self-generated at the
moment is already perfect it blooms and
Blossoms into something that was better
than it ever could have been
right right no that's exactly right so
it's I think um that's my main issues
that my problem is never with
the fact that there are so many female
characters I think what is wrong with
that really there's nothing wrong with
that I think it's that it it's rooted in
an understanding of uh of people that's
not accurate and it's espousing a sense
of entitlement that's not good on an
individual level
so what is it specifically
you give us some examples about
characters that people wouldn't resonate
with female characters that girls
particularly wouldn't resonate with and
why
I think Sylvie is a good example of that
but maybe I can think of
um you know what actually She-Hulk is
probably the best example of it
um because so much of She-Hulk talks
about
um
you know okay she she gets someone
else's power she gets her cousin's power
and her friend asks her are you gonna is
this mean does that mean you're gonna be
part of the Avengers and what does she
say she says no it's for narcissists
and so immediately there's there's an
immediate cut down of one of the most
successful stories that this universe
has told right about a group of people
that that come together despite their
you know varying power levels and
personalities and they overcome a major
super villain Thanos and immediately
it's like no they're all a bunch of
narcissists so I think she calls them
adult orphans and narcissists and it it
right off the bat says you know sets
that tone that if a group of people
choose to live not for
let's say their own day-to-day Glory but
to come together and do something that's
dangerous and that's risky that might
mean that they'll lose their lives and
some of them do lose their lives and
still they're willing to put their necks
out on the line to do the right thing
that's somehow narcissistic but then the
whole show that follows is entirely
revolved around her dating life
her out a wardrobe for some reason her
career which is you know that's fine but
the whole thing is about her and that's
okay I think on a personal level that's
fine but how is that not a narcissistic
Endeavor in itself right I think people
often now will start to look at it as
like oh if you want to put an outfit on
and fight for the little guy or you're
just doing that for yourself you're
you're a narcissist right you just want
the glory you want the brand name out
there
but if it's female motivated it's like
if she wants to put herself out there
and she wants to do
um she wants to fight for the little guy
in the courtroom instead of out on a
battlefield then that's okay her
motivations are not not to be questioned
uh and I think it's there's that like
subtle difference that I think makes for
people makes makes her a bad
representation out in the world for
little girls to to look at someone else
who's putting out putting themselves out
there as narcissists but my motivations
are never to be questioned because I'm a
female I think that's a very bad lesson
to teach anybody
that's interesting I think that you can
see this
catty
antagonistic sort of just
Petty behavior that comes through it
seems it portrays women in kind of the
most
juvenile way all of the things that for
quite a long time I think women have
been trying to dispense with this sort
of you don't know me there's this line
from She-Hulk where she's saying um that
I deal with anger on a daily basis when
men tell me about my area of expertise
and when guys look at me on the street
and when blah blah blah like you don't
know anything about anger as she points
at Bruce Banner someone that apparently
the law suggests his uh Hulk Persona is
his abused child battling with his real
adult self like you're going to say
you're genuinely going to sit there and
tell the guy that was abused as a child
that the fact that men can't call you on
the street is somehow comparable but no
because you're a man because you're
coming from a place of patriarchal
oppressive super uh how would you say
like
Advantage privilege
you you don't get to you don't get to
make a comment about this and I mean
let's just talk about the fact that
in She-Hulk when she transforms into the
She-Hulk she's able to still speak and
pick guys up and take them to bed and
stuff yeah but I mean Bruce Bruce Banner
destroys cities
yeah she
presumably annihilates guy's hips yeah
oh oh my God yes I didn't even think
about that but yes I'll try not to think
about that during the next episode but
yes uh yeah I think immediately she has
you know control over her emotions
immediately uh she can speak like you
mentioned and the fact that she compares
herself to what Bruce endured right
um but this is another way that uh
they're really driving home that point
that men are you know so clearly uh you
know worse worse than women in in so
many different ways that it took Bruce I
think something like 15 years to come
you know uh come and really I would say
integrate with his shadow right best way
to put it
um and and the fact that the story says
that he saw his mother get I think get
murdered by his father and that's why he
has all this rage pent up and here he is
offering his his wisdom his expertise
but it's it's so funny it's like her
very argument that if someone
that I have to control my anger as a
woman when men in my level of expertise
come and tell me what what to do and
here she is putting down a man that has
been the Hulk for so many years and
dealt with it for so many years and he
has his expertise and there's no room
for her to even consider that he might
teach her something irony you know
completely lost yes but that's the whole
point right I think one of my major
motivations for starting this channel
was That
so especially in the last five years I
you know it has become a very polarized
land Across the Western Society in the
way people view each other think about
each other's motivations and it's also
this this massive belief that
I should never wonder about my own
motivations and what drives me but I
should always wonder about what drives
everybody else and it's the if I am a
woman if I'm Brown if I'm an immigrant I
fall into all of those categories
I'm perfect there's no reason for me to
doubt what I should what I should uh
what I'm saying what I'm doing how I'm
treated people or treating people and
that's what I hear like I was hearing
that out in the world all the time that
people were telling me like hey you're a
put upon woman you're someone who's who
should be resentful of life like aren't
you just the biggest victim that's ever
existed and
and it's like first of all I've never
looked at myself like that and if I
don't look at myself like that then
people are like well that's because
you're privileged
so the idea that you might have a good
perspective in life and look at it as
like hey it rains on everybody everybody
has problems I don't care if you're a
Rockefeller you have problems you are
not guaranteed happiness just because
you have money that's my perspective and
some people are dealt a worse hand than
others but the best you can do is to
make the most of it and get on with it
oh no that's a very privileged
perspective that that means that you
actually had it better than other people
that you were privileged enough to even
think that way so the more I was
encountering that in the real world I
said this has to stop like at least I'm
in a position where I can address it
without necessarily easily being
canceled it's hard I mean they say women
don't have privileges I have privileges
and it's that immigrant privilege that
you can talk about whatever you want
without some oncoming fees so yeah I
mean
I can see the Allure
from somebody that sits in a movie
studio that hasn't spoken to an
immigrant for 10 years unless they catch
their Gardener or whatever on the way
out of the house to go to the
air-conditioned Studios the driver Picks
Them Up on the morning
I can see why they would think in the
current atmosphere of social justice and
upholding a victimhood as a virtue that
if we were to make a film which
completely mask off breaks the fourth
wall about how the underdog is always
the person which is who is always going
to be perfect that women and minorities
whether they be racial sexual gender
identity they are already perfect as
they are the issue is always that the
world didn't believe in them enough I
can see why somebody would presume this
is an amazing way for us to weaponize
Galvanize commercialize monetize this
current cultural milieu but the problem
is that that's not how people think and
this is what I learned from watching
your stuff that
people especially women because we've
spoken mostly about women so far that
yes it's patronizing as far as I can see
most modern depictions of women in media
patronize them I mean how does it feel
for you as a female woman of color that
also happens to be an immigrant like I
imagine that it doesn't Empower you or
make you feel particularly good either
no it in fact I feel like
the treatment based on your my color
based on my status as an immigrant
um it's as if it's a handicap that I'm
that just because I was born a woman
means I'm handicapped I feel like that's
how people look at me and it's it's not
with
in they're not looking at me with
encouragement but it's with pity and it
it makes me it makes me not it doesn't
make me feel empowered it makes me feel
discouraged and I think
this desire like you were saying the
cultural milia is that
is the rise of narcissism right and I
think that's partly what I talk a ton
about on my channel is that especially
amongst women
um the perspective has become seesawing
between I'm incredible and and and then
going the on the other side which
narcissists do all the time is that if
anything is wrong in my life
the fault lies with someone else and
their desire to bring me down and that
entire perspective creates a really hard
shell around you as an individual that
is almost impenetrable where if you need
to change and grow if you need parts of
you like Jordan Peterson would say like
if you need parts of you to die so that
you can evolve to the next level
Nothing's Gonna nothing is a lot gonna
your narcissism is not gonna let that
happen so we if we continue to patronize
women to you know patronize women
patronize people who live on the edges
of society per se even though they don't
they don't necessarily they're you know
majorities in a lot of ways
um we're going to create a culture of
people that refuse to change refuse to
grow and most importantly refuse to
negotiate with anybody and I don't know
if you come across this on online
because
I see this a lot and I specifically see
it with people that are like you know
acquaintances where there'll be a lot of
content that'll be like
um ignore the haters it'll say something
like you know forget the haters
um if anyone doesn't believe in you you
know
um f them like forget about them and
it's this this very interesting
perspective that like either someone's
with you or they're against you there is
no in between and there's no room to to
talk that out and you know there are
times that I'll say something on my
channel and I'll hear some criticism and
I'll hear some feedback and I'm like
okay maybe I was flawed in that
particular thinking and that's that's
fine this is a conversation in a lot of
ways but if but the perspective that
they're trying to sell is like no no no
no
if you said it you were right all along
they just want to keep you down
and it's just it's it's like that's you
bearing your that's you digging your own
grave if you buy into that you are
digging your own grave because there's
not going to be a successful life that
you can live with that perspective
if people aren't taught to be able to
take criticism especially if the
portrayals that they see of themselves
represented in media never take
criticism if somebody does criticize
them then there's a clap back Boss [ __ ]
moment where they tell them exactly put
them in their place and tell them and
sure enough all along I mean we're
seeing this with the Lord of the Rings
Galadriel is just permanently in the
right we saw this with the Star Wars
with the fact that the female the new
female superhero there that she was she
taught herself and then immediately was
able to destroy everybody around that I
think eternals had some sort of weird
stuff like that in it she-hulks had some
stuff like that I mean Batwoman got
canned presumably because
um
who does that is that Warner Brothers
that do that one uh was it yes it was
Warner Brothers okay so Warner Brothers
it seems can't continue to piss money
away but Disney can so Warner Brothers
are binning things that they can foresee
might not make money because I mean this
is the
the long and short of it is that people
aren't going to go and see these movies
like when I think I I enjoy going to the
cinema but when I think about going to
the cinema and then look at what's
available for me to go and see I didn't
want to go and see Thor love and Thunder
I looked at that and I was like trailer
doesn't look very good looks kind of
cheesy looks kind of stupid we'd already
seen Thor start to kind of creep into
that in the one that he did with the
Hulk what was that one Ragnarok Ragnarok
um it was kind of a bit of adult there
and I was like I get a sense that this
is going to go even further but
it's not just one of the places that a
lot of the movie studios go to is the
reason that people aren't going to go
and watch this music this movie is
because of bigotry in one kind or
another Charlie's Angels director said
that men need enough empathy to see
movies starring women because I've been
forced to do it with men my entire life
like look you are not going to be able
to guilt people into watching your movie
I learned a term have you heard of fan
baiting
no oh so this is the name for it
apparently this is the actual name
that's being given to it so
um using sex I'm assuming I'm assuming
this is what Bros is doing right yes
precisely correct precisely correct so
for the people that don't know Bros was
this rom-com but it was a gay rom-com
and very quickly it perhaps even before
it started Amazon did this with Lord of
the Rings they the rings of power they
front ran the fact that it was a very
diverse cast they played on that a lot
and what it does is they're using
the speculation and the controversy
around the production of the production
itself to generate news rather than
allowing the value of what the content
consists of to be able to carry itself
through so using sexism or racism or
homophobia are transphobia is the
justification for why a particular film
doesn't do well but the bottom line is
like gay people didn't go and see Bros
either women aren't going to go and see
She-Hulk and Thor love and thunder
either it's people within the
demographic that is supposed to be the
one which is being upheld also think
that it sucks like it's just bad Cinema
and one of the perfect examples that
we've got here especially with Lord of
the Rings I think I mean there's a lot
of problems with the most recent Lord of
the Rings which uh it's like a dunk Fest
if you just Search Lord of the Rings
Online you get the first two trailers
and then the rest of the videos are just
people annihilating it
um but you have the comparison between
Lord of the Rings and Game of Thrones
drones right Game of Thrones I mean Game
of Thrones has got a albino black man in
it with a gay son
but it wasn't the front of the the the
identity wasn't wrapped up in the fact
that they're black and or gay it just
happened to be that way and yeah I think
that
you are seeing play out in real time
what happens when casting and agenda is
forced down people's throat and what
happens when casting an agenda is sort
of naturally emerged from what is going
to make good TV
yes and you're absolutely right about
when you look at House of the Dragon you
have
you know two two very powerful women
playing out a big chunk of the drama and
none of that feels
contrived in any way it doesn't feel
patronizing because they are you you
could make the argument that they're
you're seeing all facets of each
character you're not just seeing one
side of them and so what what that means
is that there is positive and negative
aspects to each character that then play
out on the screen that just like it does
naturally in real life and that makes
for compelling story and you have a
diverse cast but it's not obvious it's
not something they're like hammering
over your head that just because someone
is black then they're definitely the
good guy I mean what happened in this
last episode showed like you know there
that no one's protected right obviously
in in the in the stories but with
Marvel and you know I chose not to watch
wings of Power by the way because I'm
I'm a really big Lord of the Rings fan
just huge Lord of the Rings fan and I it
was one of those things that I didn't
want to take a risk and like what kind
of bad taste was it gonna put in my
mouth and
um I talked about this
I think I've been saying this all over
the place but um my first biggest
frustration with rings of power is
Galadriel and that she was this
incredibly powerful feminine character
in Lord of the Rings
and her her powers were so
um they were so intensely quiet you know
and and represented
in a very powerful way but it was
without her lifting a sword right but
you when you were in her presence you
knew that she had possessed incredible
wisdom and power and there was so much
eeriness going into that situation where
then she's looking at each member of
the fellowship and she's seeing right
through them and she's reading them and
talking to them while talk like she's
talking in their heads while she's
talking to them I mean it's like really
intense power that I think can be very
well attributed to women's ability to
see things and like have intuition and
and perceive perceive what might happen
right
um I think Louis I think it was a
conversation you had with Louise Perry
did I get her name right yes that was it
by the way I loved that conversation
she's she's one spectacular yes but one
of the things she talked about is that
how women have that incredible intuition
to pick up on danger especially in men
right because the consequences for a
woman are so much so much higher
and I thought that Galadriel was a great
uh great
example of that feminine strength and
then in rings of power who cares about
that she has a sword she's you know
everybody calls her guy ladriel now
she's it's like who cares about feminine
strength it's better to be a man
obviously they did that in Thor too
sorry sorry but like I'm clearly very
angry about this but they did this on on
Valkyrie gets the title of leadership
for for just being a drunk uh but she's
not queen of uh um Asgard she is King
why
oh apparently it's better to be king
than Queen
right isn't that like the messaging that
they're saying and at a time that we the
the world had a queen you know I know
not the world but the United Kingdom
I
read a quote earlier this week and I've
been trying to put this together for a
long time I was referring to it as the
male default for a long time which is uh
the assumption that whatever men do the
masculine is preferred the the boss
[ __ ] lean in disagreeable career woman
is the path that women are supposed to
go down and if you're a mother you're a
second class citizen that's kind of been
duped into it by the patriarchy and so
on and so forth and someone said earlier
on uh female empowerment means acting
like a man
that's the new way that this is seen
yeah I mean you've taken someone that
could have been Queen which we've had a
lot and in Game of Thrones they have Qui
you're going to become Queen there are
battles between Queens Queen of the
stormlands queen of the realm
but no no no I mean what's the subtext
that that says like yes on the on the
face of it it sounds cool but the
subtext immediately is that it places
King in a superior position to place in
Queen like that's the least
a quality promoting idea that I can
think of it's so patronizing to women
absolutely completely agree with you and
I I mean and then there's also then we I
mean it's a very sensitive subject but
then there's also the degeneration of a
title like mother right
um it's like no you're a birthing person
yeah and it's it's like it's like um
it's like
reducing us to just uh
to just like flesh and Bone it's like oh
the status of mother can't exist anymore
and I think it's this whole desire that
there should be no there should be no
definitions of anything
you know we should all be person you you
shouldn't even have a name probably
should all just be a person because you
know if you have names that means you
have a hierarchy that means you have
people that don't fall that fall off of
the hierarchy and everything is you know
is destroyed from there in the way that
the the extremist left tends to look at
it
when it comes to the mother thing am I
right in saying Galadriel is supposed to
have a husband and kids
yes
rings of power they've kept them away
and it looks like they're maybe going to
try and introduce them in season two
because at the moment she needs to be in
boss [ __ ] mode but she may actually
have them already or she may meet them
in few I don't know
yeah I believe
um Galadriel
is somehow I can't I forget now but she
is somehow related to Legolas either
through marriage or something like one
of her her kids is maybe I'm forgetting
anyway but I don't know what the power
what what the plan is with rings of
power I try my best not to watch any of
it or I think I watched this like
initial promo photos and when I saw
Galadriel was sitting she was you know
in this full armor doing the man spread
with a dagger between holding it between
her legs I realized that this is not
going to be a show that I was going to
enjoy so I decided just to completely
lock it out of my my my Stratosphere as
much as possible what else are the
um
messages that you think are trying to be
promoted here whether they be uh
hierarchical racial societal gender
driven
the idea of ideological consistency
being patriarchal is one of the biggest
messages that they're trying to push
that if someone asks for logic in the
way that you think
then they're trying to oppress you
and this is like this is probably the
hardest thing to then negotiate with
it's like
it's like okay if you're saying if
you're against racism and sexism but you
turn around and do reverse races and and
reverse sexism and people point out to
you
um hey this is ideologically
inconsistent and then you turn around
and say well
um your desire to make sure that I'm
ideologically consistent is
patriarchical
and
um it just it's I think that the more
people buy into that line of thinking
the harder it is going to be to bridge
that gap of how are people going to see
each other and understand each other
um
because if you can't even understand
each other you can't understand yourself
for sure
so I think that's probably the most the
one that I find shocking
um I'll often get comments on my videos
I'll get really hateful messages
um in on Instagram Twitter wherever say
calling me a pygmy girl which is really
interesting what's that mean I don't
know that nerve
um so it's the idea you know you know
those types of girls who are like I
don't hang out with guy uh I don't hang
out with other girls I like hanging out
with guys you know what I mean like oh
girls it's just so complicated I I you
know I'd rather be wearing basketball
shorts and playing with the guys like
those are called pick me girls who or
they'll say like oh that person that
woman has internalized misogyny because
she's she she doesn't even want to be a
woman almost someone actually sent me a
comment saying you don't even want to be
a woman or you don't even want to be an
Indian you probably you know you you
pass as white and you probably love that
and uh so it's that it's that whole idea
that if you if you don't think a certain
way you don't even belong in in in in
the class that you happen to be born
into wow I mean that's that whole race
traitor thing that people come after
anybody that doesn't
decide that they're going to
agree with the current hedger money in
whatever particular group it is that
they and so okay so you you've done a
lot of stuff as well related to cultural
narcissism and the self-esteem movement
what's the how does that tie into what
we've spoken about so far
I think the the trends of
Star Wars
and shows like Batwoman that you
mentioned they are all
um selling like really neatly packaging
the ideals of narcissism and
um and I know you know it does stem very
closely with the self-esteem movement
right that the idea that
you don't need to
um you don't necessarily need to work on
something you need to instead work on
just believing in yourself and that
self-belief is what will make you
someone that's whole
and
um that's sort of you know all of the
plot lines seem to be around that right
even if you watch um
Doctor Strange too
I watched it on the plane over here and
oh I'd seen your video I'd seen you
reference it before didn't watch the
video watch the movie watch the video I
was like that is just so perfect can you
explain what the role of America Chavez
is for the people that haven't seen it
yes she gets introduced as this
character who who clearly has a very
powerful power which is to move in
between various Dimensions or I guess
you could say
what did they call it Multiverse right
Multiverse yeah she can Traverse the
Multiverse um and that's her main power
and um but she doesn't know how to
control it and you know she's they they
definitely made her a character that's
very clearly like token token uh you
know marginalized person right her she
has two moms and she's she's clearly uh
of um of South you know South American
descent and and then her name is America
Chavez and and then her she's her entire
the entire plot of the movie is
basically Doctor Strange babysitting her
and trying to you know help her out
because she's she's being hunted by by
uh Scarlet Witch
and
until the end of the movie
there's not really any development for
her uh which is real shame I think you
know that that could have really beefed
up her as a character and the final
final uh battle is really just uh Doctor
Strange telling her like hey you just
you need to believe in yourself there is
this scene does this scene where zombie
Benedict Cumberbatch comes back to say
to her I just came here to tell you that
you need to believe in yourself and you
go
okay
okay
nothing else nothing else I mean you you
went through a car crash that shattered
all of your bones you've you've been
banished to the shadow realm you've gone
and been taught by a lady who doesn't
have any hair about how to be you know
all of that all of that Journey that you
had to go through and then you've
assisted The Avengers and so on and so
forth and you're not the he's not even
the Lord's king of whatever the thing is
at the moment the head monk yeah it's
the other guy uh but no she America
Chavez because woman
she just needed to believe in herself
yeah and I think that's actually that
okay that in itself is just such a
narcissistic tweet like if you actually
die talk to someone who's very high you
know obviously narcissism gets thrown
around a lot so just to clarify what I
mean by that is that there are people
who have healthy form of narcissism
which we all we all need some level of
that and then there are people that have
unhealthy levels of it and then there
are people that uh can be diagnosed as
having a narcissistic personality
disorder and then when you're you have
disordered behavior that means that your
the way you you view the world ends up
creating a lot um creating situations
for yourself where you're not able to
you're not able to make accurate
decisions and like perceive reality
right so there's you know uh borderline
personality disorder which became this
whole thing when Amber Heard the
hamburger trial was taught going on she
was diagnosed as having Borderline
Personality Disorder so anyway with
narcissistic personality disorder
the big belief is that if I'm doing
something it's right but if someone else
does that same thing to me I'm the
victim of that that they're and that's
one of the big Hallmarks of having any
kind of relationship with the
narcissistic personality disorder or NPD
is that they they can't stand boundaries
they have they want to have a free roam
approach to their lives and their
relationships and specifically their
their work and if if they put out a
Persona which they always do they put
out a Persona that's pretty far off from
their true self true identity if anyone
rejects that Persona even slightly or
questions it
um they come down uh with a hammer but
it's sometimes it can be aggressive if
if you're dealing with you know
aggressive types or it can be like just
such an intense amount of victim
behavior that a reasonable person is
like shocked into into like retreating
like like oh my God I didn't think I was
going to hurt you that way I'm sorry I
didn't mean to say any of those things
so you know that pattern sounds very
similar to the self-esteem movement to
even even that idea that you are perfect
you just need to believe it
it's so scary and I it's quite easy
having done uh watching a lot of
different videos about criticisms online
as people via further and further uh
inflammatory sometimes right
um
it it can be used to kind of deliver a
anti-progressive message and you there's
a debate to be had about whether or not
that's something that needs to be
studied there are some aspects of what
culture that are going too far forward
however I think that the most compelling
argument here is it's patronizing to
women if I was a woman I wouldn't want
to hear that I'm perfect as I am I
wouldn't want to hear that all of the
characters that I'm supposed to look up
to don't need to go through any trials
or tribulations they're not strong
enough to deal with criticism to deal
with setbacks to do whatever I mean the
strongest character at the moment in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is what is it
not Wonder Woman Captain Captain America
Captain Marvel Captain that's it sorry
uh she's and she's basically a God who
flies around the Universe I don't know
what she does she flies around the
universe she comes back and she can just
defeat everybody straight away why and
the first was she the one that did the
Amazonian thing in the first movie and
then in the second movie it looked like
who was that that was Wonder Woman yes
okay so Wonder Woman in the first one
went through some trials and
tribulations that was pretty cool but in
the second one was kind of given all of
this stuff so you had the same character
that was delivered this so my point
being that
I wouldn't want this if I was a woman I
don't want this for the girls and the
women that I care about if I have a
daughter I don't want her to look up to
these sorts of characters I think that
it inevitably creates a fragile
environment like you say where
if you believe that any kind of
criticism of you can't be about actions
or decisions it's an existential comment
on your worth as an individual you are
deficient something is wrong with you
and that the way that you're supposed to
get back at that is a overblown passive
aggressive female version of masculinity
which doesn't look very good on anybody
least of all women uh I just don't think
that that's the sort of
media that we should put forward and
then we're seeing increasingly now I
mean the Amber Heard trial was a great a
great example of this and you've done
some fantastic stuff about uh Prince uh
William Prince Philip uh not Prince
Philip sorry Prince uh Harry and the
difference between their two
relationships
we are starting to see what happens when
this takes hold of people that are in
positions that would previously be
pretty renowned and it doesn't look very
good on them either
yes and you know something Jordan
Peterson talks about a lot is that we
know where the right
the right can go too far and we've all
pointed at that and said that's too far
and then we're struggling to do that
when it comes to the left and I mean
some people do that and other people
disagree with it that where does the
left go too far but I think it's a
similar thing it where we've all agreed
as a society where men go too far like
that's not okay if men are behaving in
that way but we're really struggling to
do that with women and saying where do
women take it too far
um and you know there was a podcast that
Meghan Markle released and she's she's
been releasing quite a few podcasts
lately and
um the one she just released this
earlier this week she talked about
um this she talks about archetypes right
what are archetypes that are holding
women back I think it's it's a misuse of
the word archetypes it's a
misunderstanding of it but what she
means is labels fine and one of the
labels she talked about was
um
being labeled crazy the women get
labeled crazy and there and she was
saying her own experience that she's
been called crazy so many times and and
that it's a way to hold women back
and
um they you know she brings in an expert
and the expert talks about how his hit
the concept of Hysteria has this you
know long long history against state
steeped in misogyny and so it's this
painting this perspective that
um you know because doctors in you know
a hundred years ago labeled women as
hysterical instead of actually getting
to the root of what they were going
through uh which you could make an
argument that that has happened you know
for people in general but um you know
again it's driven by misogyny and that
the now that has whittled down to the
term crazy and so if you call a woman
woman crazy uh you're being misogynistic
and you're trying to exert control over
them and
um
you know you look at the Amber Heard
trial and there were so many people that
were willing to believe her and then so
many people using the hashtag of believe
all women and one of the best things
about comedians but specifically Bill
Burr was that his response was like you
know believe all women like are you sure
like all of them how about like 20 of
them that are crazy that want to key
your car and it's this this idea that
like just because you're a woman I don't
know I can't believe I have to say this
but like
just because you're a woman does not
mean you are inherently good
you can be crazy you can be destructive
and that's what I like about shows like
House of the Dragon is that it shows
destructive capabilities that are both
masculine and feminine and
um even you know a show I've talked
about this in the past but like a show
like fleabag are you familiar with this
no what's up
it you know Phoebe Waller Bridge no no
you know you you probably know of her
because she was the one who came in and
helped rewrite do some rewrites for
James Bond for that last film and people
were pretty angry about it because they
consider her sort of this like feminist
feminist writer uh but I actually I
think she rides that that line pretty
well and she wrote this show called
fleabag it's a two season show it's on I
think Amazon Prime and she uh you know
I'm sorry for spoilers I'm just gonna
give it away to you because I've brought
it up now but
um she is a character who's very
self-destructive and
um she does a lot she definitely does a
lot of things including hooking up with
men
um and that make her unhappy she herself
identifies that as making her unhappy
but there's this whole season leading up
where
um she she shows to the viewer because
she constantly breaks the fourth wall
and she's letting them in at very
specific times where she shows the the
viewer that her best friend passed away
and the way then we find out is that she
walked in front of a bus and then for a
long time she hides the fact that the
reason she walked in front of a bus was
because the main character and her her
only name in it is fleabag is that
fleabag slept with her boyfriend
and that's why she and and when the
viewer finds that out you know you see
her completely unravel because it was a
fact that she was hiding and it's
beautifully done because it shows that
uh you know being feminine is incredibly
powerful in a way that can be incredibly
destructive there's a lot of chaos that
we can create ourselves we don't need
men all the time to create chaos right
which is the overarching belief right
now so our way of creating chaos is that
we have a deep perception of human
emotion and we know how to unravel
people there's a reason why it's much
easier for a woman to win up when when
an argument in a relationship with her
husband it's much easier right and if we
don't recognize that if we don't
recognize that we have a dark power in
us then we actually are likely to use it
inadvertently on people all the time and
um I know I've been referencing Jordan
Peterson here and there but like one of
the things that really struck me
and I think it was something that really
changed my personal trajectory
was I was watching his lectures I think
this was back in 2016 before before he
like
absolutely exploded but
um one of his lectures talked about
helping people understand that you would
be a Nazi guard and I hope I can say the
word naziano yes he doesn't love it
um that you would be and I don't mean
you but like me I would be a Nazi guard
if everybody wants to believe that they
would be the hero and uh they would be
Schindler but they would probably be a
Nazi guard because of the fear and and
and every you know there are all these
different things that go into it and if
that if a person an intervention
individual can recognize about their
dark capacity then it's less likely to
turn into this like massive pathology
that exists in society and I think
that's what's happening now is that
people are becoming less and less
convinced of their own in internal
Darkness becoming more convinced of
other people's Darkness
and that's I think that's a pretty
dangerous place to be one of the most
obvious places I think that this is
starting to show up is in a movie critic
scores diverging from audience scores
and the performative empathy that's
happening by the people who have
something to lose if they go against the
dominant ideology whatever it is that
they're supposed to put out there you
know most of the scores on Rotten
Tomatoes are Anonymous or they're done
by a username that you're never going to
be able to track back to somebody so
they can say whatever it is that they
want and maybe there is uh what's it
called review bombing which Amazon
turned off the first 72 hours for Lord
of the Rings rings of power and then
extended it for another five days in a
desperate attempt to try and stop people
from giving a realistic review of what
it is and that was labeled with misogyny
and racism so on and so forth but
it seems to me that
the powers that be the people that
believe they're supposed to be the elite
media class that know what's good for
everybody that will point at the plebs
and remind them that you really should
just put your faith in us
they are failing increasingly to
resonate with the people who are living
a normal day-to-day life perhaps this is
because of inequality you know the kind
of life that the people who are going
into Hollywood offices now is going to
be even further away than most of the
people that go to see their films versus
30 years ago 50 years ago 100 years ago
for sure you know you think I always
think about this when I watch
um archive footage of sports games and
stuff you know from the 1930s and stuff
like that and these professional
athletes they would they were basically
the same as the people in the stands
except for the fact that they were well
known the only difference was really
their Renown and their lifestyle in
terms of their routines not in terms of
the quality of life that they lived they
do these interviews with old British
footballers from the 1950s and the 1960s
and stuff and they lived an all right
life but it wasn't insanely different to
everybody else but we now have this
Divergence in terms of Lifestyle we have
a Divergence into terms of the ideology
that people follow the values that they
have what it is that they think should
be upheld and increasingly as that
happens people are struggling to the
powers that be are struggling to find a
way to resonate and the only thing it
seems to me the only solution that they
can find is to be increasingly Brazen
with outright virtue signaling because
well if I can't get you to like what I
do at least I can guilt you into feeling
good about it that's the closest I think
that they can get
yes and you're absolutely right about
that difference between celebrities or
you know uh athletes from because it's
kind of similar
to the kind of scale that everything
achieves now right even if you look at
um companies the size of companies
because the whole world is accessible as
a product versus you know your corner
shop that existed in the 1920s where you
you probably were face to face with the
business owner and he cared about his
reputation with you and same with
doctors doctors knew you and your family
and you know it I think everything has
become so scaled up that each um each
brand has access to millions and
billions of people and so
with with what happens I think with
celebrities is that they get Scaled up
so fast for doing something
like compared to how much they get paid
and how much uh how much their lives
change overnight if you look at what
their work is it's not that different
from any other job
and I think there's a level of
insecurity that they start to experience
that I'm I'm looked at so disparately
from who I really am and I'm living this
you know even if you look at Johnny Depp
right and Johnny Depp talked a lot about
this during his trial that after after
he was in um
Pirates of the Caribbean his life
completely changed he could not live
sort of the normal life that he used to
going going and grabbing coffee just
couldn't do things like that and to him
he's he's clearly not someone who's made
for celebrity and never really
internalized it in the same way but you
can also see him completely unraveling
from that and having a really bad drug
addiction and alcohol addiction and like
getting very scared about the people who
are around him like the whole cabal of
of Amber heard's friends were basically
living off of him in his like several
penthouses and and that's that's sort of
the life that happens but then with
other people and I think this was kind
of true with Brie Larson is that she was
completely normal great down to earth
person and then she became very famous
because of her Oscar win which you know
her acting was incredible in that movie
I think it's called room or the room one
of those two and
um suddenly she just I think she just
bought into her own hype we really
intensely but there's like a guilt there
like do I deserve all this Fame and then
I'm living so apart from a regular
person and I have guards around me and I
have Gates around me and so there must
be a reason that I'm here so I need to
speak for other people and I need to go
and constantly I have a responsibility
and so someone asks her at the Red
Carpet like what does it mean to be a
woman in Hollywood and she says it means
it's really hard and if you're a woman
of color it's really really hard coming
from a person who's like what's so hard
about
Your Existence in Hollywood what exactly
is hard about it you were you have you
have a a great voice like people are
listening to you they're looking at you
they're paying attention to you what is
so hard to be a woman in Hollywood but I
think that helps alleviate that guilt
like oh at least I'm taking all this fee
these feelings of insufficiencies and
turning them hopefully to help people
but in the process just creating this
like victim narrative for myself
because that helps to hopefully bring
down the gap between where somebody is
in terms of their status and the work
that they know that they do if they can
manufacture artificial oppression that
outwardly appears like the Gap has been
reduced down I actually do have to go
through it's not just the time learning
lines and being on set it's all of the
the expectation and the oppression and
the victimhood and all of that stuff
that I've got to get through as well
okay so I had I had a thought
that has come up a bunch of times when
thinking about the role of media and
what it's supposed to do do you think it
should be the role of Studios to create
something which is popular or to create
something which pushes a virtuous moral
ideology taking away the fact that we
don't think much of the ideology that's
being pushed at the moment is virtuous
what's the role of a studio here
I would say
I would say the role the true role of a
studio is to
tell stories that resonate with people
and if you if you do that
um
it's not about necessarily like
morally what's right or wrong right if
you if you because I I know what I'm
about to say does talk about morality
but
a lot of the great stories
and the reasons why actors became
became something that we really looked
up to it's because what what do they
represent right it's the story and I
think a lot of actors of old even if you
look at Leonardo DiCaprio or or even Tom
Cruise though sometimes he breaks he he
broke out of it a couple times but like
they try to keep as much
um like you know
what am I thinking of like a fog around
the actual lives and who they really are
because let them instead be immersed
into the world like Christian Bale does
a great job of this like I don't really
know who Christian Bale is as you don't
really get a sense of his personality or
anything except for the fact that he is
very dedicated to his roles and so he
immerses himself and plays those roles
in a way that is heavily believable and
you know certain movies and certain
books really resonate with people
because they become this guideline of
how can I live a life that's going to be
meaningful and if you tell stories
around that
every everything else becomes irrelevant
at P things like just make sense like
why why is a movie like
I don't know what I was gonna but like
The Dark Knight is a great example of
this right is that there are so many
moral conundrums in that in that movie
and the questions are hard to answer
even the question around
um uh you know where uh fox wants to
uh fox wants to shut down the system
that Batman built where he can hear
listening on everybody's personal
conversation and yet Batman feels uh you
know Vindicated in that because he he
knows that if that's what's gonna it's
gonna take to take down someone like the
Joker and it's it's like morally you
could take either stand but what's
wonderful about that movie is that it is
a deeper exploration of a hard to answer
question on many different levels and I
think stories like that that then
resonate with something that you're
dealing with in your life like you
personally are grappling with and then
you look up to someone and you say okay
they're struggling with it I'm
struggling with it I can start to piece
together the answers in a way that's not
just the easy way out
and I think those are the stories that
and whether whether these movie
production companies want to do that or
not is irrelevant because the market is
going to speak after a while and they're
going to have to change course but that
those are the stories that are going to
to work and if you look back on even
movies and then sometimes like I look at
shows and movies from 19 to 1990s and
then the early 2000s and it's that's
those are the kind of stories they were
telling
and that's what was like sticking with
us
that is the main question I think that I
always have in my mind which is how long
can a desire to push a popular ideology
continue to last in the face of an Ever
dwindling Capital liquidity like just
how long can movie studios and Disney
plus continue to I mean how much was
Batgirl was like 50 million or 100
million and they bend it before it even
went to edit I think they'd filmed the
whole thing like they've done a hard bit
they would send it to edit but no we're
just not going to bother I don't know
what the do you know what the relative
proportion of budget that would be spent
on edit versus on filming is
I've heard that it's like close to 20
okay so the Lion's Share of the cost for
producing this yeah get it out there
right they've already done some
marketing although marketing is probably
going to be a bit a good bit on on top
and blah blah blah but still the point
being that
there are changes being made that either
Aquaman 2 or Aquaman 3 obviously it's
got a lot of Amber Heard in so they're
like retroactively trying to unperson
her I don't know how they're going to do
that
um yeah but
what do you think is going to happen
given your view from the lofty media
critic
Mountain what what do you predict for
the next few years of movies are we
going to see more Top Gun or are we
going to see more She-Hulk
uh
um content that these activist writers
you know pseudo writers really their
activists that have sort of taken over
uh various companies they would they
would have argued that oh no there's no
appetite for a movie like Top Gun
because it's so oriented towards
weaponry and uh and the Navy and
Military and yet it did so well and I
think that that's such a great
indication and I think even uh
Spider-Man no way home is such a great
um indication that if you prioritize
story and you respect the intelligence
of your fans
um then you you will get a good result
out of it I think
um this is going to go on for quite a
while because there's there are there's
all this good will that got built up
um with good storytelling with Marvel
they had 11 years of really good
storytelling and great characters and
great movies so even though we know that
Thor love and thunder is an absolute
Abomination
um it's still made I think close to I
think maybe it's crossed a billion
dollars by now I haven't checked in a
while but
um and it's that was all based off of
the the Goodwill from Thor Ragnarok and
and the rest of the series because
people there is an appetite to go see
these movies but does it have the kind
of earning potential
earning power that Top Gun did
absolutely not and will the next movie
The taika White TV does will it will it
have as as uh great of an earning
potential it won't I think everything is
going to whittle off very slowly and I
think it's it's highly likely that for
at least the next five years we're going
to continue to see this
Domination by activist writers because
they're also now all installed in very
they're embedded positions yes the and
the cultures have have really absorbed
them right they've they all believe in
this and they think of us as
um that we're on the wrong side of
History right they think that they're um
you know their Schindler and where you
know where the Nazis or something and
and that they'll they'll win out in the
end and I think
um as long as
um
as long as there are there's an
introduction of intelligent people that
can see beyond all of this
um into these kind of environments which
is not going to happen I think I think
all those people have gotten slowly
kicked out I think um until that happens
we're not going to see a change more
likely I think we'll see new powers come
up new sources of content are going to
come up
um and I I think it'll be you know in
the form of definitely YouTube content
or Netflix because Netflix is already
given out that word right that things
are changing that if you are woke you
can get out I mean that was a very
Brazen move and I think Netflix knows
that it doesn't have the kind of staying
power that Disney does it needs to get
its act together it uh otherwise it's
going to be it's going to be gone so I
think look from Netflix we might start
to see some major changes
um I I agree completely about not
respecting the intelligence of the
audience I think that it's that
patronizing pointing at the the plebs
down in the the peasantry as they walk
past and saying we know what's best for
you
um but as well you're right you know if
you've installed a group of people that
have a victimhood complex that are
dealing with this narcissism
if you do decide to get rid of them
they're going to kick up a pretty big
stink and it's very easy to lay the
issues of a poor performing series or
movie at the feet of people who don't
know what's good for them I mean Bros
was a perfect so perfect of an example
of this and I don't know how many times
it's like the 2022 has just been a
sequence of releases that have fallen
flat on their face and it's the same
formula that gets rolled out to explain
it oh it's because of bigotry it's
because I went to go and see movies with
male leads so can you come and see mine
like are you really hoping to guilt me
into watching your movie like is that
really the stage that we've got to like
is it not good on its own merits is it
not sufficient is it not sufficiently
capable to actually get me to want to go
and say no I have to go I have to go and
see it with a gun to the back of my head
because I don't know what's right for me
yeah it'll be it'll be interesting I
really hope that that's not the case
um
but
foreign
I suppose that there's so many different
layers as well
the director the producer the execs the
studio the publisher the marketing all
of these people the scriptwriters all of
these people at different stages you
only really need one of those to have
this sort of
ideology
for them to be the person that puts a
stop on it all right even if you had
everybody else was on board with one
particular thing because you're always
going to have
the flag of victim or oppressed or
marginalized and everybody else that's
around that is well I'm not going to
touch that that is the sort of thing
that I get canceled for so I'm not even
going to try and push back against this
and say well maybe what you think is
right for people maybe we should have a
strong female lead who is strong in a
feminine way maybe we should have a
strong male lead who isn't a complete
imbecile
it's gonna be very hard for them to get
that through
yes and this is sort of an unrelated
example but my my friend who lives in
Oakland
um you know he there's the crime in
Oakland is outrageous if you're not
familiar with that so California in
general
um has had a really intense surge in
crime since um uh since covet hit and
San Francisco is one of those cities we
you know car break-ins are very common
but Oakland's crime has been um is
really intensely steady steadily On The
Rise and a big chunk of the population
in Oakland is African-American so it
makes it for makes for a very sensitive
subject and there are a lot of shootings
that have been taking place
um and a lot of people have been losing
their lives I think they reported
something like the 100th shooting that
took place this year
um that was fatal uh if I might be wrong
on that number but
um
and my friend plugged in because he's
he's lived in Oakland for about five
years now and he plugged into a city
council meeting as a it was happening
live and one of the people was making in
this argument that can we please
increase police presence in particular
neighborhoods that have high instances
of murder and and crime and immediately
the response from one of the other
people was absolutely not those are
predominantly
areas with African Americans so this is
clearly a very racist policy to request
that and immediately the argument was
shut down there was no more room for
discussion and I understand that I
understand because
along with everything else happening
there's also the you know in intense
fear that everybody has at the idea of
being canceled and to be labeled I mean
we throw around the word racist so much
but if you think about it it's like that
is one that is a very intense
uh insult to throw at someone that you
would be that that
um
you know you would be that terrible of a
person that you would judge someone on
based on the color of their skin but so
everyone is trying to protect their own
reputations but it comes then at the
cost of the bigger Vision right I don't
want to be called racist but at the same
time you know one could make that
argument that like African-American
people are dying as a result of this
supposedly anti-racist you know
discussion happening here right
um and it's the same thing I think in
these situations that if anyone
questions the making of bros being a
very
um you know very specific movie which is
fine I think people can go and see
movies about gay people I think I don't
think there's anything wrong with that
but in the trailer one of the people
says
um guys remember straight people and
someone else says yeah they had a good
run
and it's it's like okay do I really want
to go watch a movie where
um it's very clearly pro-gay and
anti-straight people
and it's like I don't want to be scolded
for two hours like I would rather go do
something else and um and I think in in
a movie like it in the production
process of a movie like that if anyone
has a reasonable question even then
they're probably afraid to voice it at
the risk of you know because they might
get called anti-gay or bigoted or
anything and that's the biggest fear uh
you always have to Pander to the woke us
common denominator
yes
baggage claim ladies and gentlemen where
should people go if they want to check
out your stuff online I absolutely adore
your YouTube channel it's blowing up at
the moment where should they go
search for baggage claim on YouTube but
I have a lot of my content uh you can
also follow me on Twitter baggageclaim11
and I'm also on Instagram baggage claims
with an s
I appreciate you thank you
thank you so much for having me on I
really appreciate it what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]